das sogenannte bundesamt für ausrüstung
in koblenz darf also demnächst pro jahr
24 milliarden mehr ausgeben für uns fort
ulrich von heesen ulrich beherrscht
jetzt wahrscheinlich partystimmung oder
vor sylt welt so einfach ist es nicht
hier im bundesamt fehlen aktuell 1400
mitarbeiter
das heißt nur eine handvoll beamte muss
diese unglaublichen massen von geld
ausgeben was sagen sie zu hauen die
behörde sucht händeringend leute hier
die stellenanzeige
wir suchen erfahrene geld verbrennen sie
gerne schwachsinn kaufen
wer nicht funktioniert wem ist wer
bestimmte rüstungsprojekte zu spät
geliefert werden also alle
rüstungsprojekte dann kann man denn da
nicht einfach ins nächste jahr 7
der verfügt erdrutsch zurück in onkel
schäuble steuertopf im schlimmsten fall
wären der kindergärten gebaut so eine
scheiße sagt braun
also muss man das geld rechtzeitig auf
für irgendwann ja hier guck mal die
neuen goldenen handgranaten bilder die
seiner glücklichen 4 handelt die
kollegen und jetzt kommen 24 neue
milliarden dazu hier
er hat gerade 30 neue barofsky panzer
bestellen kannst du für alle brand
kurzem planung war auch der
flugzeugträger philipp rösler sondern
haben sie gemerkt ja gar keine flugzeuge
ad hoc meldung unser
bruttoinlandproduktes schon wieder
gestiegen
jetzt müsst ihr 24,2 milliarden
zusätzlich war ballard es schaffst du
schon schreibst du nicht mehr geld
bedeutet eben auch mehr probleme
und das schlimmste ist das amt hier
wurde ja schon immer von lobbyisten
belagert aber seit das mit der zwei
prozent regel durch ist drehen die
rüstungsteile ein schöner anblick
[Applaus]